The Fallout from the fighting in
Khartoum is playing out in the heart of
the Sahel
some of the harshest Terrain in the
world
vast and remote places that are no
stranger to conflict and War
from the air you can get a real sense of
how arid this landscape actually is the
temperature is incredibly High it is
very hot and the riverbeds down below
are bone dry
those who arrive from Sudan cross the
empty wadis in search of safety and
water
most are women and children some have
been here for hours others weeks
Halima Muhammad and her family arrived
12 days ago
her husband and father went to buy
supplies in elginino the main town in
Sudan's West Darfur region
they haven't been heard from since the
violence broke out a few weeks ago
I'm frustrated we didn't get any news
from them we need tents we need Jerry
cans we need blankets we need food
[Music]
everyone says they are afraid of being
caught on the wrong side of the fighting
African masalid communities here blame
African Arab groups for the violence
I swear to God
kill and beat people we have small
children vulnerable people blind people
and we all came to protect ourselves
they just burn everything
the Arabs don't leave us alone when they
come they kill and rape and burn and
we're vulnerable if we let them they'll
burn our houses with the people inside I
saw this in the last war in 2020 I saw
it myself they burned people and I
buried them with my own hands
not all people say they are fleeing Act
of fighting but the fear of what may be
coming is real
the conflict in Khartoum is worsening
the threat of communal violence for
people in West Darfur a rumor is enough
to send entire communities in search of
safety
newly arrived refugees from Sudan often
find shelter with friends and family in
villages on the chatty inside of the
Border but this is also a fairly common
sight in this part of the country people
crossing the dry riverbeds crossing the
wadis coming into Chad and finding
safety under the shade of a tree
wherever they can
Generations who've grown up hearing
stories of war and past tragedies
are on the Run scared they might be next
Zane Bas Ravi Al Jazeera gungur Eastern
Chad